somewhere caught between parallel
Dimensions is the Containment Breach to
end all containment reaches countless
unnumbered and nameless anomalies on a
Warpath to destroy what has become of a
now unrepentantly evil Foundation a
testing site rendered distorted and
unstable under the power of countless
reality warping objects and me caught in
the middle of it you're probably
wondering how I got here well for
starters I'm what's known as an anomaly
if I can see something I can crush it
using my brain I guess you'd say I'd
have a form of telekinesis but find
control or remote levitation are not my
forte I'm not sure who I was before the
GOC apprehended and brought me here to
this strange place a place ruled by a
cruel man named Elliot Emerson and the
even cooler Foundation that he directed
A Place Called site 13 and as for the
rest of us contained here we don't get
numbers The Only Name I have is the one
I gave myself if I am destined to be
trapped in this infernal place by a man
named Emerson I may as well
self-identify as his equal and opposite
you can call me throw and this is the
story how I managed to survive 100 days
in site 13. well after everything went
haywire ah here goes nothing day one
like I said before this all began with
the Containment Breach 2 and all
containment breaches it is chaos in the
hallways with anomalies running rampant
everywhere most are taking revenge on
the guards and researchers but not every
one of the unnumbered is in solidarity
the crystal butterflies and the mimetic
Scribe are indiscriminately going after
anything that isn't them including each
other as for me I'm wearing a
specialized helmet that keeps me
blindfolded it's a power suppressant
since my anomalous ability only works on
things I Can See Clearly I'd love to
remove it but there's no way to find out
which guard has clearance deactivate my
headgear when things are this manic as
much as I'd love to celebrate the
Reckoning of site 13 I decided it was
better to stay inside myself today let
the record show that if the foundation
or the GOC do crack down on this I was
well behaved during the breach day two
it's gotten marginally quieter out there
I don't think the fighting has stopped
as much as it has moved out of the Halls
where I've been contained the foundation
hasn't dropped off any more rations
today so I start to think that maybe
this really was the big one what if
everyone somehow got out I started to
wonder about some of my fellow anomalous
humanoids and if the Containment Breach
had given them a chance I don't really
know what they look like because most of
the time I'm forced to wear a blindfold
to suppress my Powers but I have been
able to pick up a few hints through
listening there's a clown named Bobble
he was already here when I arrived and
no he's not a guy dressed as a clown but
like a genuine actual clown he's nice
enough but I get the impression he'd be
a bad influence on kids if there were
any here other than Elijah of course
he's known as the leech boy since he can
drain the blood from people with his
hands scary stuff really I don't dislike
either of them but I'd rather not take
my chances running into them during a
containment reach I guess I'll wait out
this one a bit longer I had water from
the containment unit sank if I needed to
satiate my thirst and a day without a
meal wasn't exactly something new day
three I felt the strange rumbling in the
air this morning like everything in the
entire universe was picked up and
dropped back down somewhere else I don't
know how else to describe it I once
heard some of the guards talking about a
reality bending machine called the
thresher on the lower levels could it be
the work of that thing day four my old
friend Bobble the clown actually came
through for me he has taken up residence
in the digital interface of my cell and
is giving me details of what is
happening out there the funniest thing
about this clown is that he lives side
of electronic devices Bobble was never
threatened by my abilities because they
only work on the physical world the most
I could do to him is crush a television
set where he was dwelling our friendship
is based on the fact that the two of us
are among the only things inside 13 that
couldn't cause harm to each other and
sadly I think that my list of enemies is
much higher than Marbles and a lot of
the things out there might hold a grudge
the reason I hadn't been thrown into the
fire is that my matter compression
ability is useful to the foundation I'm
not proud to admit it but I've agreed
multiple times to use my abilities to
bring some of my fellow anomalies
particularly the larger ones down to a
manageable size for disposal my reward
for this is that I'm not subject to some
of the more deadly experiments here
though it's not like these evil
unethical scientists can resist some
light torture did I mention how much
these people hate anomalies because make
no mistake they hate us a lot bubbles
said he couldn't stick around but that
there was an untouched supply of rations
a few cells down that eye as an organism
that needs to eat to survive should go
and find even with the blindfold it
shouldn't be too hard for me to get
there I'll think about going tomorrow
day five as I felt my way through the
hallway to the other cell I could tell
that things had gone really off the deep
end there were people fused into the
walls no doubt because of one of the
other anomalies and I had no idea
whether or not they were on my side
there was no doubt that memetic Cognito
hazards were scrawled all over the
surfaces of the facility as well if the
Scribe had truly been on the loose he
definitely have made those brain
destroying symbols he always did maybe
by current lack of vision was a good
thing especially because spending so
much of my time blindfolded had enhanced
my sense of smell from the inside of a
nearby open cell I caught wind of a tray
of day-old Foundation rations and what
what luck they were the same kind
usually given to humanoid anomalies like
me these must have been the ones that
Bobble had mentioned I settled into this
new cell and enjoyed my first full meal
in days day six with the power
suppressing device still firmly on my
head getting out of here scene like a
pipe dream I spent the day thinking
about the only other person inside 13
who was kind to me Dr Hadley she was a
researcher who took care of some of the
humanoid anomalies even though she's
working with the foundation I get the
feeling that she's actually a really
good person deep down maybe it's the
Stockholm syndrome talking but I really
wish I could see her face she always had
sympathy for Elijah the leech boy and
saw him as an ordinary kid despite his
blood-draining powers I can only hope
that both of them are safe day seven I
continued to make my way across the
facility hugging the wall as tightly as
I could I could hear weapon fire
throughout the facility and countless
anomalies battling it out all of a
sudden I was caught off guard when I
heard several footsteps coming towards
me these must have been Foundation
Personnel I thought a shot rang out and
I was hit directly in my headgear by
some kind of piercing round fortunately
the suppression device was strong enough
to take the hit for me so I didn't take
direct damage and it was equally
fortunate that being shot at had caused
it to malfunction I could now remove the
headgear and blindfold and stare down
the group of armed Foundation guards in
front of me it's the crusher one of them
shouted my name is Thoreau I responded I
didn't give them a chance to fire again
and using my ability to defend myself
was the only way out after all the
anomalies I had compressed at their
orders doing the same to Emerson's
forces came all to naturally to them we
were merely objects things to be used up
before were incinerated whether we're
human inhuman or something entirely
Indescribable it made no different to
Emerson and his underlings since all of
us are going to the same place after
that encounter with the guards I decided
that I wouldn't use my powers to harm my
fellow anomaly we had all endured so
much in site 13 that it felt needlessly
brutal to let the one thing that I had
in common with the other prisoners be a
weapon against them I couldn't guarantee
that all the other anomalies would treat
me the same way but the idea of living
by that principle filled me with a sense
of purpose from now on it was me against
sight 13. I would survive and escape to
the outside world day eight to my
surprise there was a mundane vending
machine in this terrible place I used my
powers to break into it breaking in the
delicious Bounty of chips protein bars
and fruit snacks this stash would take
care of my sustenance needs for a while
so I stored them in a military pack I
had taken from one of the guards I had
fought with the other day day 9 I began
to realize that the rooms I was
traveling through were repeat themselves
it was hard to really notice at first
with all the Cognito hazards I was
trying to avoid but it seemed like site
13 was reshuffling itself in a way that
had made my progress through it
completely circuit to us while this
meant that my encounters with dangerous
anomalies and guards had been basically
non-existent it also meant that I wasn't
making any progress towards Escape Day
10 through 14. yep I'm officially stuck
in a loop now this was probably
unavoidable even if I had a mental map
of the facility or even a physical map
reality is so broken by the effects of
the thresher that I don't really know of
the rest of site 13 even still exists I
honestly wouldn't be that upset if
director Emerson and the rest of the
foundation Personnel had been flung into
Oblivion that would be worth it even if
I spent the rest of my days here
wandering around and eating vending
machine food day 15. I gained access to
a new area of the facility only to find
that it was a stairwell filled with a
terrifyingly black gooey substance I had
no idea what this stuff was but perhaps
it was best not to touch it yeah that
would definitely be for the best still
there were stairs going away from the
goo which could lead me closer to an
exit so I decided to take that risk and
Sprint up to a higher level as if
waiting for a cue the look would begin
to rise as soon as I set foot in the
stairwell I climbed the stairs as fast
as I could but this stuff was determined
I thought I could slow it down by
crushing some of the stairs but using my
Powers caused some of the substance to
Splash onto my hand it didn't hurt
freaky but it definitely could have been
worse I made it out of the stairwell
otherwise intact and thankfully the new
floor I found myself on wasn't anywhere
that I'd been before there were Giant
Leeches everywhere falling through
cracks in the wall did Elijah do this
day 16-27 I continued making my way
through the unexplored sections
encountering a lot of the remains of
dead guards but no fellow anomalies
beside the leeches I made a point of not
getting too close to them and they
didn't seem to bother me either most of
the leeches seemed content to drink the
blood from the of which there were
plenty there were fewer Cognito hazards
and I was grateful for that I managed to
find and crush a few more vending
machines to restock my Food Supplies
compared to the rations I had been fed
since I was first brought here these
snacks practically tasted like gourmet
food on Day 28 Bobble found me again or
rather I found him he was inside of a
laptop in one of the abandoned research
offices we compared notes and it gave me
some idea of what happened that caused
so many of us to escape apparently Dr
Hadley had stood up to Emerson and
sabotaged the incinerator I guess she
truly was a good person a lot to thank
her personally if I happened to find her
still alive somewhere in all of this it
could have also been her who activated
the thresher machine but I wouldn't put
it past Emerson to do the same of course
he would have done so in an effort to
take the rest of us with him isn't it
remarkable that the person we think we
can trust and the people who hold us
prisoner Mike wanted up taking the same
action for completely different reasons
it could be that my embarrassing little
crush on Dr Hadley was stopping me from
seeing the bigger picture in any case I
thanked Babel and pressed onward day
29-39 while the reshuffling of the
hallways and rooms had considerably
slowed down my exploration of site-13 I
can safely say that I'm making progress
towards finding some kind of way out
I've come to realize that the further I
get from the lower levels where the
thresher is at its most powerful the
more stable the facilities layout
becomes if I can make it to the rooftop
then I'm as good as free so my guiding
philosophy has become onwards and
upwards day 40. now this is unexpected I
was confronted by another group of armed
Foundation Personnel different uniforms
one of the mobile task forces I think
but instead of shooting me they just
started asking questions the most
confusing of which was what is your
object class and SCP designation number
I had no idea how to answer were things
that different in the other containment
sites site 13 had never given us numbers
or formal classifications Beyond Simple
nicknames derived from our anomalous
properties I wasn't sure what was going
on but I also didn't want to risk
getting put back into containment I
couldn't be sure this wasn't some kind
of foundation trick or I hadn't somehow
lost my mind because of some Cognito
Hazard I'd accidentally glimpsed I
crushed a doorway using my powers and
ran for it a few shots echoed behind me
but the apparent leader of the mobile
task force called for them to hold their
fire whoever these people were they
definitely weren't with Emerson day
41-52 if the leeches repeating
staircases and occasional hostile
anomalies weren't enough now I have to
deal with these alternate Foundation
Personnel poking around here it was one
thing to protect myself from site 13's
dedicated guards so since they'd been
responsible for holding me captive but
my conscience was telling me not to
attack these new mobile task force
agents instead I hid from them as well
as I could running to another area
whenever I was discovered I can't
remember where I heard it from but I
know there's some old saying about great
power and great responsibility point is
I didn't want to have the responsibility
of having used my powers to hurt people
who didn't deserve it still it seemed
like many of the anomalies didn't feel
the same way from what I observed during
my secretuist route around the facility
I could tell that these mobile task
force agents were suffering losses day
53 on day 53 I found a lone agent
huddled in a fetal position against the
wall of one of the containment corridors
it seemed that no other members of their
squad were present so either they had
been separated in The Madness of site 13
or they were the sole survivor either
way I felt sympathetic so I approached
them in an effort to communicate what
what I learned during this conversation
absolutely blew my mind it turned out
that the thresher activation had caused
site-13 to literally jump universes and
wind up in a timeline where the
foundation and the GOC had never joined
forces in this reality the foundation
was a comparatively benevolent
organization that only sought to secure
contain and protect anomalies it rarely
destroyed anomalous beings unless those
beings posed an existential threat to
other life according to the agent I
spoke to if a humanoid anomaly like me
were to be contained by this version of
the organization I'd most likely be
given free room and board and three
meals a day even if Freedom was my
ultimate goal I couldn't say that life
didn't tempt me I agreed to help this
Foundation agent find the rest of their
team as long as they were telling the
truth day 54-67 the mobile task force
agent and I worked together to search
the facility for other Foundation
Personnel not ones on the payroll of
Scyther team I should clarify it was
nice having someone to talk to even if
they were coiled in fear when I
mentioned my best friend was a clown I
guess a lot of people in this Dimension
have an irrational fear of clowns by the
way my new friend said that their name
was agent Ben McDowell and apparently
site 13 was the most dangerous site that
their Force had ever been deployed into
I couldn't say that I was honored
especially after all this place had put
me through but the nightmare was far
from over because on day 68 oh God day
68 the leeches surrounded us and were
out for blood agent McDowell had only
limited ammunition and I was still
incredibly hesitant to use my powers on
other anomalies of course my resolve was
about to be pushed to its Breaking Point
as an enormous mutated leech arrived at
our location it was the biggest anomaly
I'd ever seen and yet there was
something uncannily familiar about it
Elijah could it be the Super leech
lashed out at 8 McDowell with its huge
tentacles and pulled them into its
terribly toothy mouth I ran away as fast
as I could should I have felt bad that I
left my new ally behind with a giant
monstrous anomaly yes I was only Human
After All but self-preservation had
kicked in at the time and my mind hadn't
fully accepted that I should be
protecting someone dressed in the
foundation uniform over another anomaly
I'm sorry agent McDowell at the very
least I won't forget your kindness days
69-84 I was on my own again wandering
through the facility as it twisted and
changed trapped in a dimension that
wasn't my own with freedom feeling even
less possible now that I knew there was
an entirely different Foundation after
me now I never saw Elijah again or
rather the horrific thing that Elijah
had become I made a guess grimly that Dr
Hadley was probably gone by now so many
lives have been lost because of the
cruelty of site director Eliot Emerson
if I found him I would make sure that he
paid for the hell he put us through day
85. on day 85 I did find him there he
was screaming as he was pulled along the
wheel-like face of a terrifying many
armed God I couldn't stare too long
because the wheel was covered in Ruins
that were Cognito hazards but I got a
good enough look the man responsible for
all of this was now being tormented
himself I wouldn't have been capable of
a better punishment on my own so I left
him to his fate day 86 through 100 it
took me 15 more days of searching for
staircases before I made it to the
rooftop of site 13. when I got there a
foundation helicopter was waiting for me
unfortunately it was the foundation of
this new dimension one that would
provide me food and shelter for me like
a human deserves and never subject me to
experiments against my role as I watched
site 13 get farther away from inside the
helicopter a smile cross my face for the
first time in 100 days now go check out
I survived 100 days in scp-3008 here's
what happened and I survived 100 days of
scp-001 when day breaks here's what
happened for more crazy 100 days
challenges